et bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
édition du skyco édition spéciale sur le
Big tour au Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines avec nous
Patrice Carmouze bonjour Nicolas alors
surtout nos premiers Christophe Cousin
bonjour à tous les deux bonjour à vous
Patrice Bégué directeur exécutif de BPI
France créateur du Big tour et
Christophe Cousin donc président de
win-win déjà
et on accompagne en fait BPI dans
l'organisation de cette formidable
tournée parce que c'est quand même un
sacré job c'est formidable tournée qui
se termine à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines
Patrice bégaye absolument on a démarré
le 5 mars dernier dans une région
merveilleuse dirigée par Jean Renner on
arrive dans une région merveilleuse avec
avec beaucoup d'énergie dans la région
Île-de-France et 51 Yvelines en
particulier alors Valérie Pécresse
m'avait dit tu verras c'est
extraordinaire c'est méga extraordinaire
Jean-Michel fourgon toutes les équipes
font un travail vraiment colossal et
nous on ne Reda d'avoir ces 300
partenaires donc Christophe pour monter
en fait cette opération là parce que
dis-moi de tourner je crois qu'en France
on sait jamais vu et ça fait quoi
combien de personnes ont assisté à ce
big tours alors en fait sur le plan
physique c'est à chaque fois 5 7 8 10 15
20 minutes ça dépend des des étapes et
puis tu as toute la partie digitale
aujourd'hui c'est 37 millions de
Français ont suivi en 10 mois donc 37
millions c'est énorme grâce à nos 300
partenaires 200 partenaires médias toute
la presse continue de régionale toute la
presse hebdomadaire régionale le groupe
français division le groupe Canal+
franchement toutes les radios les uns
des radios toutes les télévisions
locales en c'est ça revivre la France et
puis c'est un peu ça des pays toute la
France vous avez accueilli nombreux
entrepreneurs sur votre plateau le
plateau vive la ville c'est ça quel
bilan vous faites de tous ces
entrepreneurs français il y a une
caractéristique entrepreneuriale
française oui
l'amour du maillot France les valeurs de
simplicité de proximité humaine de
volonté d'optimisme et puis se
déterminisme ce que j'adore c'est
permettre aux entrepreneurs
d'oser grandir pour servir l'avenir
c'est exactement ce que fait Christophe
dans son entreprise c'est à la fois ce
point GPS loin le tableau Excel aussi
parce qu'il faut savoir compter et puis
amener parce que aujourd'hui vous
fédérer des équipes dans l'événementiel
mais dans n'importe quelle entreprise
c'est grâce aux femmes et grâce aux
hommes que vous arrivez à faire des
exploits comme celui-là et je tiens à
rendre hommage à Barbara papassian et au
120 personnes toute votre équipe
vraiment extraordinaire et est-ce que
vous disiez c'est que si grâce à ce
bictou vous avez donné l'envie à des
jeunes de créer des entreprises Paris
gagner Paris gagner aujourd'hui 50% des
jeunes de l'entreprendre 30% des femmes
et il faut donner tous les moyens aux
jeunes et aux femmes vont réussir
très simple plus de crèches pourquoi
parce que la responsabilité si vous
voulez d'une femme dans une entreprise
c'est la même que celle d'un homme avec
pour moi les femmes avec des talents
supplémentaires pourquoi parce qu'elles
ont une finesse elles ont un sens de
l'entrepreneuriat je vous le dis
beaucoup plus fine que nous plus fort et
plus fine et c'est ce qui change aussi
dans le sociologie de l'entreprise alors
Patrice dans cette émission spéciale
skycle on va recevoir beaucoup
d'entrepreneurs demandant à Christophe
qu'est-ce qui vous a donné l'envie
d'entreprendre la liberté
je n'ai jamais
accepté un certain nombre de contraintes
et j'ai toujours voulu faire ce que
j'avais envie de faire voilà et
entreprendre c'est alors c'est parfois
se tromper mais en tout cas c'est avoir
toujours ce syndrome de liberté et
cette capacité à faire le choix être
libre et ça c'est savoir prendre des
risques et les assumer oui mais en fait
les risques en tant qu'entrepreneur on
les calcule il faut pas croire que on
est des
curieux mais le fait de d'avoir la
décision et de ne pas être tributaire de
tel ou tel tableau Excel ou autre
pour moi ça a toujours été important
j'ai été
collaborateur trois semaines et ça s'est
arrêté
on apprend la liberté et voilà les trois
semaines m'ont fait comprendre que
justement
pas n'importe quel risque justement
c'est tout le rôle de la BPI d'aider les
jeunes entrepreneurs à prendre des
risques c'est combien 50 milliards
51 milliards 51 milliards sur la French
Touch sur la french Fab sur le coq vert
et en fait c'est ça on permet aux
entrepreneurs allez je vous fais un jeu
de mots d'avoir le statut de la liberté
voilà c'est un petit peu rebondir sur ce
que tu dis mais c'est aussi
je suis désolé mais ça va pas plaire aux
banques mais c'est la seule banque dont
on est fier d'être accompagné tous les
entrepreneurs disent je suis sélectionné
ou accompagné par BPI et cette fierté
d'appartenance au grand club des pays
c'est quand même un truc formidable qui
a été créé par BPI France voilà
j'ai connu Oséo
aujourd'hui quand on dit BPI France on a
les yeux qui s'allument mais tout ceci
est possible grâce aux équipes les 3300
salariés des pays France que je salue
mais aussi à nos clients avant le covid
on avait accompagné 80000 entreprises
après le covid c'est plus de 700 000
c'est énorme quand on disait à un moment
que la France n'avait pas les
entreprises les choses ont changé
comment on l'adore on adore parce que en
fait ces femmes et ces hommes qui
entreprennent cette liberté dont tu
parlais cette vision c'est ça vous savez
peut-être le métier d'entrepreneur oui
c'est peut-être le métier le plus dur
mais c'est quand même le plus beau alors
il y a France 2030 il y a des objectifs
il y a des secteurs sur lesquels il faut
il faut avoir des aides plus fortes ce
sont lesquelles c'est créer les
champions de demain alors il y en a
beaucoup dans dans l'hydrogène dans la
culture dans les batteries en fait les
secteurs c'est les secteurs de 51
Yvelines vous allez avoir beaucoup de
chefs d'entreprises vous le disiez tout
à l'heure qui vont se succéder sur sur
votre plateau mais c'est exactement ça
en fait aujourd'hui même des vieux
secteurs innove quand on disait la
voiture est hydrogène par exemple
aujourd'hui tout le monde réfléchit et
il y a quelques années c'est la voiture
électrique bon il y a des vrais
électriques et des fausses électriques
en fait dans les produits il faut jamais
mentir aux clients au consommateurs donc
cette dynamique là que nous avons de
permettre aux entrepreneurs de les
grandir servir l'avenir en fait quand on
est dedans quand on vit avec les
entrepreneurs un truc que tu as pas
encore au fond de toi c'est passé
entrepreneur il faut passer à
l'entrepreneur voilà faut pas poser quoi
il faut oser et osez vous maintenant
et bien merci à tous les deux merci à
vous merci beaucoup et continuez
j'espère que le Big tour aura lieu
l'année prochaine aussi ça continue
absolument hein parce que c'est vrai que
c'est c'est un facteur parce que on voit
bien quand on voit les les exposants il
y a plein de gens qui sont intéressés
qui ne sont pas du monde de l'entreprise
forcément qui sont intéressés aussi par
votre démarche et qui se dit c'est
peut-être le moment
voilà exactement
merci Christophe merci c'est bien c'est
Yann Crouzat Leo de l'accord et Lionel
Thomas le directeur général d'intermès
ils vont nous parler exactement ils vont
nous parler de leur collaboration une
PME ou une uti qui compte collabore avec
une start-up voilà c'est parti et on
lance cette bonne chance parce que en
fait c'est nous qui avons fait la vidéo
en motion 3D
pour l'accord bravo super merci beaucoup
merci à vous
[Musique]